scarred bruised marked like human
cargo weak from Days of abuse and
torment at the hands of the Israeli Army
Palestinians men of all ages being
treated for injuries sustained in
custody they were rounded up when
Israeli troops entered Gaza City in the
north of the
strip we were taken and beaten with
wires and struck with cold water were're
beaten hard they kept us for five days
they gave us drops of water two times
every day my father diabetic and they
took him to the toilet only one time and
they humiliated him they kept him almost
naked the abuse and mistreatment of
Palestinian prisoners across the
occupied territories while not new has
reached fever pitch since Israel's
invasion of Gaza these are very horrific
uh testimonies we are very concerned
about the safety and life of the other
detes who we know nothing about them the
Israeli authorities apply a new regul
ation on Gaza prisoners they are treated
as unlawful combatant which allows the
Israeli authorities to keep them for up
to 45 days without contact with any
lawyer or with the outside world and
also allows to keep them in Israeli
military bases rather than to put them
in Israeli regular Israeli prisons under
Israeli prison authorities the testimony
of those released back into war torn
Gaza an insight into the Fate being
suffered by prison prisoners still in
Israeli
hands these images show men detained in
bethia in the northeast of Gaza accused
of being Hamas Fighters accusations
denied by those that knew them stripped
and carded away in humiliating fashion
their Fates unknown only a small sample
of the horrific images coming out of
this war of the violence and
dehumanization Palestinians are being
put through every day Zan basravi Al
jazer ramala in the occupied West Bank